today
and we will be switching from games to
Stats
go ahead
Define switching
hi thank you so much for having me here
I must say I was super excited to get on
this plane I don't love travel as much
anymore because it's exhausting one but
I'm so excited to get on this flight and
come here because it's been a long time
since I went to a workshop or conference
where I know some of the names from
papers that I've read but not all the
people that are coming
so uh and I'm excited about a difference
in opinion
and a difference of approach that we
have because it's been actually
inspiring so I mean Illinois tech which
is in Chicago and I'll tell you a bit
more about this at the very end um so
stay tuned
the most of the results in this talk are
a result of a difference in opinion okay
so I'd like to tell you uh forgot my
water I got to tell you a story or maybe
two stories uh and I would like to try
to stay a little bit at a high level so
please allow me to spare you all the
technical details because I want to sort
of get to the punch line with other
technicalities but I'm happy to discuss
more okay
so I have a colleague at Illinois tech
who does graph Theory really well in
optimization and I was telling him how I
was working on the project with um
actually all every now look who's in the
audience and Steve Feinberg at that time
and one of the questions we wanted to
study was what happens when you have
Dynamic networks right networks evolving
over time so you have now time time
period one two three four five and this
goes on forever how do you
do fill in the blank your favorite thing
you want to do right and for me the
question I wanted was how do I model
this evolving data from uh some familiar
standpoint that I can understand and my
colleague said this is super easy you
just aggregate the five networks that
you have into one multi-graph and you
know you do whatever you need to do
okay what this and so of course I argued
back because it doesn't make any sense
to me why would you have a sequence of
evolving time evolving networks and then
you Bunch them together into a multi
multi-graph
why would you do that from his point of
view it made perfect sense because this
is the sequence of observations it's
just you know an edge over and over and
you count how many times
so I thought okay
here's the here's the question that I
came up with after this argument with
him is is this multi-graph the union of
these graphs okay a good summary of This
Time evolving sequence
he said yes I said no so let me try to
quantify what it needs to be a good
summary and can we have conditions where
I'm satisfied from a stats point of view
because he's satisfied regardless okay
so this is sort of the starting is the
question clear right so
when do I want to allow my friend to do
this if I think statistically
and so to put some formalism into this
and no you don't have to remember any of
the notation but I need something to I
can explain so I'm going back to a 2010
paper Hanukkah fluency on Terror guns so
temporal arrogance temporal exponential
family random rough models okay so I
have a discrete time marker chain
as a sequence of T observed snapshots of
the network
so at time T some you have a network and
then time t plus one query depends on
time T there's some transition right
and so in this paper they had a very
natural way of modeling this they said
you know you have the joint likelihood
of this sequence
uh from time one to time T is done
present of course there's a starting
point so a condition on the starting
point
um right so I represented the sequence
of factored conditional probabilities
sure right
um I mean I'm not saying it's the best
way but this is the approach that we
start from and then what do
probabilities look like well I use
statistics of two consecutive networks
yes this is true when it's markovian
right yeah yeah right
you're assuming yeah I'm assuming I'm
not saying this is the best
sorry I should have put it in red or
something so it's true when I have a
microphone all I'm saying is you again
you may disagree and say I don't want to
do a mark of Shame that's fine
I'm just starting from here right or I'm
not they were they Sorry to the setting
and so then what is how do you how do
you model this well you have a
probability of a transition from time T
minus one to time T So this conditional
is this nice exponential expression and
these are these statistics that somehow
measure change from Network at time T
minus one to network time t
okay
and so I have this l-dimensional you
know Network statistics summarizing
these changes and you know the
corresponding natural parameter and so I
sort of understand what this looks like
from a stats point of view I'm sort of
happy right
but
this is a mark of change and this looks
like an exponential family thingy and
what happens when I aggregate them
so
right
is a paragon and ergo
there's a I'll tell you about these
acronyms that my student who is a native
English speaker likes to mess with me
with okay
um so is this
can you write
this
in ergon form because it's called a
ergon so it's an ergon right
wrong
so I just asked so Billy schwart was a
student of my friend himanjukal and then
I just post this question turned into
half of his thesis so it was not so easy
to to answer
so I just said just take this temporal
ergon and write in as an ergon please I
would like to understand the sufficient
statistics of this aggregate data or
whatever the heck it is okay and so he
spent several months doing this please
allow me to say all the details of this
one of these results but I'll just sort
of snapshot the theorem from his thesis
which uh does its best in doing all the
formalism and exponential families
writing down this joint likelihood okay
and there's an issue
in the normalizer in the in the
partition function how we want to call
this there is a dependence on The
observed observation and time at a
certain time okay
so I have
the denominator depends on the if
Network so I actually
can't
it is not true that a terrorism is an
ergo always which greatly upset me
because I really wanted it to be an
aircraft because it's called a teragram
so then I just said fine well when can
you get rid of this dependence okay
sorry like deriving this would be uh 17
slides of mess so I don't know I don't
want to derive it okay well not this but
like the theorem so it turns out that
the punch line of these results is that
you can massage this expression to turn
it into an exponential family form if
and only if you look at the transition
Matrix of this Markov chain and it has a
specific property
it has to be what we're going to Define
uh as a permutation uniform okay
so I'll give you a couple of small
examples from the literature and I can
give you more examples from
um the paper but they're just they fill
up the slide too quickly okay
so I said one sufficient condition that
allows this tagum to be an ergon
is this thing called permutation
deformity every row of the transition
Matrix is the permutation of every outer
row
so it looks like it's a super
restrictive condition okay but uh I have
there are several examples that are
sitting out there so this is the
simplest one
uh and you can relate this to some of
the well-known uh well-known models like
other regressive models in Peter Hoff's
paper 2015. and what happens is when
this condition is satisfied
this picture
works and you have an exponential random
multi-graph model on here and all the
statistics from this network are
interpretable in terms of that and all
the parameters of this model interpreted
in terms of that okay
that's the punchline yes there's a
question
why why the Mardi Gras easy dialect
I'll tell you
so he oh sorry for those online the
question was why is the multi-graph easy
to analyze so from you know from a stat
point of view I actually have a an
answer that I'll get to in the second
part of my talk
but uh
naively literally this was just a
satisfying curiosity but actually
many people think that multi-graphs are
more complicated than graphs I think the
exact opposite
sorry one more question so I mean going
back to the multi-graph it seems like
the only time it should be a good one is
if it's somehow permutation invariant
right because if you're taking like a
temporal Network and then somehow
combining it into a multi-graph then
somehow you're saying that the order
doesn't really matter
so that's so this so This condition is
exactly what lets you get rid of
temporal dependence so it it's actually
the theory uses conditional exponential
families markovian exponential families
and relating the two
and I didn't want to have to do all
those definitions and so
um
what
this is the condition that tells you
exactly when you are allowed to get rid
of temporal dependence and it's
different than dyadic or Edge dependence
and so on it literally tells you yes so
Lisa had a question
you can also just repeat it
yeah
implies about what can actually change
in this network from time T to times so
intuition about what this implies about
what can change in an effort yeah what
can change um Let me give a couple of
examples okay so actually three examples
so it seems like it's a super
restrictive condition makes it a little
bit nervous and so in this paper they
had four different examples and two are
and two are not yeah so the microphone
game
you're stuck with it you have to ask a
question
so the first the simplest example of a
teragram they had in their paper is
called they're using the density as a
sufficient statistic of this transition
so tau is a sufficient statistic of the
exponent family that was used as a
transition from time to the next time
and it's basically a scaled well it's a
density of the graph okay number of
edges divided by number this is and you
can think of this as it's a model that
tells you there's a tendency of an edge
to exist in the future irrespective of
the press because you're just trying to
preserve the overall density of the
graph right
and in that case your times time
snapshot you have IID other training
models but then this sum is a training
multi-graph
right that's it okay and
um this may look very Elementary but we
able to just use this I mean I have an
exponential family that's super easy
it's like an interest rating and so
we're able to write down a closed form
mle uh rather than having to use mcmcmle
for Doing Network estimation and
uh we've had like after you're done with
this you go well obviously you're going
to have a close from Emily however
before re-expressing the model in this
form they actually had to use
accidentally it was not at all clear
that the closed form exists because you
had this microbial chain and no
multi-graph representation so that's the
first win that I get it's super easy for
me to get the mle compared to the
um if I if I Bunch it in a multi graph
okay
the same was the case here but I sort of
suppressed the rest of the details the
second example is stability
so maybe you're gonna say I don't like
this other model because it's not
preserving anything about a specific
Edge only the total graph density so in
this model they call Tau the stability
is the number of edges in the complement
of a symmetric difference of the two
graphs what so a is one graph B is the
next time you take the symmetric
difference right and then the complement
and then you count the edges and so um
to interpret this you think this is a
tendency of an edge to continue existing
or not in the future if it is presently
doing so so I see an edge The Edge
really wants to stay
I don't see another really it doesn't
want to be there okay so this is a smart
setting this is basically going to be
everything right
it's far setting this is basically going
to be everything because you're looking
at the component
I guess
yeah yeah then it's not going to be
extremely informative no that might be a
problem no right so you may have a
problem in sports you may have a problem
this makes no assumptions about the I
mean they're just giving they actually
have this just this different four
models for temporal arguments and they
didn't discuss
the mathematical constraint you may want
to put on the graph itself and but I yes
it'll be great
and so the third model and this is
something that the the Billy Billy came
up with so it's in the paper and uh
um I would like to say that this is the
hammer now I need a nail so I need a
data set where this model works well for
and I don't have one yet okay so we're
calling it the model of loyalty
um because it's like a beta model but on
the terram
um oh I forgot all the other names for
the beta model but I guess you know
he said uh generalized random graph rank
one model hidden variable model soft
configuration model take your pick
that's right okay so does that on tario
right so
so I have a degree sequence of a graph
right and then
um
my um
I am looking at the degree sequence of
the symmetric difference
okay
of the two consecutive graphs I know
this is a and b this is graph at time t
a graph time t plus one yes
just more mostly a clarification
question is there a nice example of Tau
a b where you don't look at ages but
look at higher subgraph counts of the
difference maybe
I have not seen because that would you
know that would make the class richer I
agree right right I have not seen it
thank you so everything that they they
they were doing these small things and I
think it would be awesome to do that
next and maybe someone did it but I
haven't seen the paper so
yeah
Let's uh let's work it out
okay so why is this called loyalty
because basically
um you have a parameter for every node
right these are node parameters now in
my in my uh expensive family and so this
parameter for the node tells you how
much how loyal that node is it it goes
between let's say 0 and 1 and if you
have a low value near zero then you're a
loyal you're sort of like prefer not to
change right you got your edges around
you you're gonna stick with the edges
that you got and maybe you're going to
switch a few friends around at the next
time spot but if you have a high value
of this parameter closer to one
you're just changing friends like you're
changing socks
as time goes on right so it it seems
like a very nice way to express what
happens over time and I'm searching for
a wealth you know
even better the interpretation so it's
just to show that there are different
different uh levels
of
I'm missing the word of English
you can specify these models of
different scales right you can look at
globally what happens on the graph or
locally at the vertex or as I this is a
great suggestion to look at this other
subgraph counts but the ultimate goal is
you want to have that I wanted to have
the multi-graph make sense so I wanted
to have the total bunched model as an
error
okay
and so because then this IID sequence of
graphs that happens over time is a
single observation and it's not just
about how I'm summarizing the data if
the statistics that I do on the green
multi-graph can be interpreted in terms
of the parameters and everything else
that I should have done on the on the
temporal scale so that's the key right I
don't want to have some silly summary of
the data and I can do statistics here
but then I cannot go back and interpret
in terms of natural parameters of the
original markovian a chain of grass
right
and so
um that that was sort of like the
satisfying answer and Billy called this
ermgrum
he puts an M for the multigraphs and I
can only pronounce it once in a day so
let's call it ergon okay but it's a
multi-graph right
um so this is this story at least clear
of sort of
so
yeah if and only con if condition this
condition is you have a transition
Matrix for a Markov chain and in that
transition Matrix you want to have
um the normalizing term be the same
across all rows
and this is not something that's
um
I don't like to hold it in my hand when
I'm working so instead we ended up
interpreting it in terms of a p
uniformity uh because this has a number
so the perform mutation uniformity would
hold if you control the Delta of the
subgraph cons
why not
I think I need to sit down and think for
one second to answer that
hopefully but I could be completely
wrong
I've never thought about it
you're gonna get me thinking instead of
talking now because and also this is
good but I don't I don't know
I continue to talk
I mean I yeah this is a thing okay so
right so this is the this is sort of
where the multigraphs come from and now
this part of the story is the reason why
I like the multi-graphs okay and so um
um as a person doing statistics and so
the next several slides
um
I would like to tell you
a short version of a story of what we
can actually do for these multi-graphs
okay and why I think they're easier to
analyze than uh simple graphs okay but
not always but in the ergon setting yes
okay
um so the tools that I use come from the
area called algebraic statistics and
whenever I say that in this group I get
the question what is an algebraic
statistic so let me tell you what is on
this what does this field roughly about
okay
so I usually want to answer this
question you're given a candidate model
in one graph such as this multi-graph
and you want to decide whether this can
be regarded as a draw from some
distribution in the model so this is the
goodness of fit problem okay and I know
this is not always a question you want
to answer but it's a question always I
want to answer I always want to know
whether model fits the data when I see a
network
and
um the story is that you can have
undirected networks directed networks
now you can stick into this group time
evolving networks under P uniformity uh
you can have covariates on the nodes all
kinds of stuff and any of these uh can
be bunched together
using algebraic statistics tools and you
can develop a finite sample test rather
than the asymptotic test for goodness of
fit
um and there are a bunch of challenges
that come with this okay so I can tell
you a very nice story which is you know
there's a theorem in the 90s that said
how you interpret this and then
um there always exists such a test and
then the ugly part of the story is
nothing really works for networks
because they're roughly sparse and I
don't mean Network sparse necessarily
but I mean one observation of an edge
and you had a multi-graph up to 100
multiplicity that one is a sparse number
in terms of statistics
um you have a problem with sampling from
these models you have a problem in terms
of convergence I I have statistics I
have no power
because networks are weird like this
okay so there's a million questions to
answer
so let me tell you how we deal with
these challenges okay so think about the
fact that a network like it's you can
you can view it as an infinite Matrix or
tensor if there's also a problem with
estimation right I don't have a problem
of excavation
I'll tell you what in exponential one
yeah in general but in log linear
exponential and graph we don't and why
not I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
wait for that yeah yeah two slides I
think if I don't tell you remind me okay
so a network is an incidence Matrix or I
say tensor because if the network is
directed you may not want to just have a
you may have have different options here
right so can't I just borrow stuff from
what I learned in categorical data
analysis right I have a table of numbers
and I know how to analyze that table I
mean I continue the table so I want to
just do the same thing there there are
tools so let's use them
um and so what are these borrowed
insights that we can do so let me
explain to you what I mean
by a table or a tensor okay
so
this is a very simple question but
anytime I pick up a textbook and I don't
really mean a textbook but I mean like a
paper right that tells me how to analyze
tables all of the results don't apply to
network tables okay and it's frustrating
and this is why suppose I have I don't
know if you can see this so well because
something happens with the projection
but I have an endnote directed Network
and I actually want to encode it as an N
by n by two by two table
no idea if you can see can you see
what's on there
on TV screen as you can see
well I just wanted to I don't know
it's I have
an N by n and then in each cell of an N
by N I actually have
um excuse me what is this a 2x2
I forgot my Dimensions okay so every n
by n actually has a two by two entry why
because uh I'm it's basically denoting
let me blow it up
it's denoting a um
two
this is the note that you have no Edge
between two vertices this has an edge
from I to J this way this has a natural
I to J the other way this has a
bi-directed edge right because in a
directed graph you can have all these
four configurations
right and so I have a multi-graph that
is directed if I see an edge from one to
three three times
then I have a number three here in the
one by three by whatever this is one by
Zero Entry right
and so on so you can count how many
edges so this is a n by and by two by
two table and so it just classifies how
I saw my edges in the graph and I put it
down and that's it's a simple count okay
and so it's a it's a community table so
I can do the same thing that fisher does
proficially for for exact testing of
independence of two things right it's
like literally looking at the chi-square
statistic and you're done you move on
uh but what are the new challenges that
I have when when this is actually a high
dimensional Network
so the story is a bit
um
long
um so I'll give you the short version
uh every time you can write down your
air gum so that it corresponds to a
model on such a table I call it the log
linear error okay so uh I don't know how
many of you work with log linear
contingency table models on a daily
basis so I thought I'd do just a very
quick uh one slider on that
um so if you have a large dimensional
table you know D1 by D2 by whatever DN
in this case I have a three by three by
two a log linear model is an exponential
family such that the sufficient
statistic is some linear function of the
table
that's the definition of a log linear
model right
so if my air drum has such a sufficient
statistic then it's a log linear model
and that means
that means that the edge accounts are
actually independent right
yeah so they will imply it will imply it
will imply right that certainly makes
life much easier it will imply okay
right no triangles
I love triangles but no triangles here
yeah but the example uh so I mean this
is like a the simplest example what does
it mean a linear function well you can
Envision it on the table right like
you're just doing sums across different
dimensions but I like to flatten my
table or flatten my network into this
large large vector and then I have this
huge Matrix for the design Matrix for
the model right so if you define if you
give me an exponential family like this
all you need is this Matrix a to specify
everything else
okay
and so Feinberg in the 60s
um sort of explored model geometry of
these models and
um so you know looked at the
Independence model of two categorical
random variables uh you know he took the
model model industry with the
probability simplex and actually uh you
can write down that the corresponding
equations of the segre variety
all right so this is Berkeley I'm
allowed to say cigarette variety because
msri is just up the hill so this is an
algebraic variety something in algebraic
geometries it's a set of solutions to a
system of polynomial equations that
lives in complex space however the
polynomial equations are exactly the
independent constraints somehow on the
table so all you're doing is
intersecting a complicated algebraic
geometric object with a probability
simplex
okay
so the beautiful thing about it is is
that that object is also specified by
this exact same Matrix a
that object also is intimately tied to
the neighboring field or sister field
which is community algebra which tells
you how to do a lot of computations with
this a while respecting the model
okay and so here is how one can do an
exact conditional test for any linear
exponential family like this while the
infamous family
You observe
a graph
you oh no a table but okay you read the
table G is a graph You observe a table
and then a times U is the observed value
of the sufficient statistic
right and you define a set that's called
a fiber which is sort of all other
tables that have the same sufficient
statistics
therefore the same probability under the
model therefore the same mle
right but they're different graphs or
different tables and
if you're able to enumerate this set and
organize it score it give every table
and that's at the score you're able to
come up with
a goodness of fit test is the observed
table
closer or farther from the expected than
the rest of the tables in the fiber
if this sounds weird this is exactly
what fish's exactness does literally
everything give everybody a score and
then just compare it and put them on a
histogram and you know right
and so the problem is I said if you can
enumerate this set
When U is of size 1000 by 1000 by two by
two good luck enumerating a set of
anything where a times U is a fixed
number right
I mean I don't know nobody knows how to
do this and so we cannot enumerate so
instead what we do is we sample this set
okay and if you have a good way of stamp
this is obvious right if you have a good
way of sampling the set then you have a
good way of approximating the p-value
for the goodness of it and you're in
business
and the theorem that tells you how to do
this appeared in 1998 in the annals of
statistics by the economists in
stonefields
um and it basically says there is such a
set called the Markov basis that allows
you to do this uh sampling of this step
this fiber and in principle it can be
computed
uh for tables of oh as many as six rows
okay because the computer will break
when it has more rows but in principle
anyway it's computable so you can do it
in your own business so if you're
curious about what microbases I don't
want to Define them further I wrote an
AMS notices what is article and um it
has references in it so hopefully that's
easier but it's literally a set of moves
that allows you to make a Markov chain
on this set yeah
all right the problem is that these
moves I mean
so here's how I got into algebraic
statistics in 2010 what did we say seven
okay two years 2008 when I actually
started so I visited uh I bothered
Feinberg enough with like oh come on you
can do this what is it what is it he
said just come on visit you're too so I
came to visit he said do this he gives
me this problem on a network and I said
oh that's easy I know a markovitz is
when I put it in a computer I press
enter and I waited for hours and I got
80 000 elements in the market basis
I printed them out just because I
printed them out I was a grad student
I analyzed them all by hand because I
was aggressive
and this cover there's really only 10
that mattered and the rest is either a
permutation or a throwaway or whatever
and then and then he's like oh great now
let's just do it for Network that has a
hundred nodes
but the point is this is theory that
guarantees existence and finance as a
set of moves Computing them is
ridiculous and there's a paper by Dobra
because Geographic statistic that says
none of you all can compute any of this
so let me give you a dynamic algorithm
instead and it's really the only
scalable approach is to compute these
moves dynamically and there's a lot of
research on how to do this well how to
do it for Network so it's somewhat of an
open problem so it's not an open problem
theoretically but it's an open problem
in practice which is what I'm trying to
do
okay
and so what are these log linear
arguments where you may be uh I didn't
tell you anything about the mle
and just look at your real I remembered
in these models you compute the mle
using iterative proportional setting
and that's uh what three lines in r
and it is done in no time but here
everything is independent then life
should be easy everything works
absolutely so
so that already
but yeah and that I know but I I promise
so and the other thing is in tables what
does it mean to have a simple graph
versus a multi-tool graph
it's whether you have zeros and ones
here or where do you have up to capital
n
having zeros and ones is worse because
it's a sparse table
and you have less room to move around in
the fiber and you have a lot more
complicated moves to reach all these
other tables in the fiber if you allow
yourself more Freedom by allowing
multiplicity and edges you actually have
faster algorithms and the estimation is
the same complexity
right so because I forgot there's a
graph I just put it in here
I mean I didn't forget but I I don't I
don't do it in the graph space
so
made it disappointing that these logins
are all linear and so I don't have
triangles however I'm very excited
because it's still uh you can tell I'm
excited I should not have had to say
that by default
oh
it accounts for a lot of models so as
long as there's no triangle
um so you can see the uh coloring here
indicates whether or not the class of
models is a log linear error okay so
this micrograph models of frankenstas
and anything related that has triangles
does not fall into this class
I mean you can write it as a Linux
measure family but I don't have this
linear sufficient statistic so I cannot
do what I said I could do in the
previous slide
um
there's a graph on in this paper
hence I'm in the gravel workshop and I'm
one of the authors so that's why I fit
it but anyway goodness of it uh but
everything else like the directed random
graph models of Holland and Lionheart
the beta model extensions of it to
hypergraphs uh using K stars as
sufficient stochastic block models
degree characteristics
with covariates uh uh you know
all kinds of other stuff fits
there's a we're gonna ask
aren't the case Stars the same as the
beta model
I don't know
sure I think they are sure
but I'll do this later yes
why does the stochastic model fit that
doesn't look like independent edges
because the table so um right so in this
paper that we wrote for February volume
so with Elizabeth and vishesh we Define
specifically precisely what it means to
be log linear and uh it has to be log
linear on a table so what is the
corresponding contingency table
and my answer to that it has to be
something I'm calling now diet
classification table so in case of the
sbm it's not an N by n it's an N by n by
K by K
uh okay so I'm using the block uh mem
the block membership of the endpoints of
an edge
as a
um category to classify my diet my Edge
right and in that case you have this
huge table but you still have linear
statistics
I see now Remco should be happier
and in case of unknown Community blocks
in case of unknown blocks this is
ridiculous is a mixture model of uh
login exponential families but we are
able to extend to that it just doesn't
fit in the class we're able to still do
that as well
so it's it's
you know
I just fit quite a lot of data even
though I'm missing the triangles yeah
um and so I sort of summarized
um I sort of already told you what we
can do
um but a lot of questions come up
um questions that in networks pose
problems pose a little bit less of a
problem for me from the point of view of
tables so you're gonna tell me I have
this week of nodes where no edges are
allowed to happen
or I have this forbidden star graph or
whatnot to me that translates to
sampling constraints or structural zeros
if you really doesn't actually matter
from the algebraic point of view on the
table so certain cells are zero and
they're never allowed to move
there's actually a theorem that tells
you how to still do this Markov chain on
the fiber and you still have convergence
and everything else I had a master's
student a few years ago who proved
for a certain model that you actually
get rapid mixing of this chain which is
as good as it can get
the Master's thesis or he didn't prove
it for everything but he proved it for
like a large portion of the models that
we were studying
um and uh what we actually do is we use
graph Theory to generate the moves to
sample we use log linear models to do
the estimation using a threaded
proportional fitting and then we use the
algebra to do the walks on the fiber so
this combo of different tools allows us
to go actually reasonably large okay
so
uh that's sort of what I gained and um
there's some issues still remaining for
example what is the goodness of the
statistic that you use so you sample the
networks that have all the same
submission statistic you need to
organize them like like in the exact
testing what is it excuse chi-square may
be constant
so that's useless so you need to come up
with new goodness statistics perhaps
number of triangles should be a good
statistic I have no idea okay so this is
open this is where sort of it's got
we're still working on it okay but for
the model that I had on the previous
slide we figured it out but in general I
don't know what's the recipe
okay and just to sort of um
uh
prompt more differences in opinion maybe
um vishesh and I uh were invited to
write a comment paper on the jianjin's
uh
um uh paper on the on the
co-authorship and citation network of
statisticians so they collected over the
years this really important data setup
you know it allows statisticians to
analyze themselves as an authorship
Network and uh these are different
graphs right so this is a co-authorship
where there's a niche or you can't see
the blue or some of the names that are
famous but it doesn't matter so there
are edges here I swear I can't see
anything it's uh so the n Edge means
there's two authors have written a joint
paper together right and an edge here
means this author has cited that author
right
now these are simple graphs
in their data set yes so what are those
two blue clusters the blue is just the
name of an author they were trying to
say I can't remember who it is they're
just putting famous statisticians saying
oh here's this guy okay so maybe to
prompt them to read a paper
I don't know I should have I could have
deleted it but I didn't and so what we
did is you know oh oh so what they did
is they actually you know did I mean an
amazing what we're collect and cleaning
this data it's actually thresholded data
so there were more than one edges
obviously if you read a paper together
we probably have seven papers together
and then there's seven edges here so
they thresholded it
have at least this many papers together
then you put one Edge so we make an
argument of why you shouldn't do that
you should keep a multi-graph and then
but even when you do that uh people tend
to rate US by saying she has seven
co-authors and 37 citations and I don't
like being evaluated by numbers like
this uh yet I always am right we all are
and so we asked the question is a no
degree a good summary of this data
okay so this is a simple question can
you can you rate me whether I deserve my
raise by the number of co-authors and
the number of citations right
and the answer is one is yes and one is
no how do I arrive with an answer I play
num I say this question
is equivalent to saying that this data
comes from a model where the degree is a
sufficient statistic if it ain't
sufficient don't summarize it with it
right so if that is a sufficient
statistic then that means that the model
the beta model and the the P1 which is
the directed version of it fits the data
and here it does
and here it does not
and you could argue well citation
indices are what people use and don't
you should not at least not for this
particular data set maybe because of the
threshold maybe because it's a small set
of statisticians maybe because it's all
from six staff journals I don't know
okay but I like to answer this question
because this can be done within a couple
of minutes on my laptop and the network
is quite large and I'm quite confident
it's good because I ran a a walk of
length one million for both of them I
mean on a broken laptop now okay so I
said let's invite the difference in
opinion because
that's almost controversial now because
you know I'm telling my Dean not to
evaluate me about my citations yet in my
research statement I put the number of
citations because I know they're gonna
do it
yeah well I mean in this I mean I'm not
in this data set yeah so okay because
these are the top six journals from
whatever year to whatever year in
statistics that for top three generals I
can't remember so and it's a small year
period time span so I'm not even in here
but you know
perhaps there's more to the data that
was lost by thresholding so you say your
address number might be a better number
to judge it which I wish I knew the
answer to but yeah maybe
see mathematically satisfying answers no
okay so um there are some I I will not
talk I just put this here because I've
seen somebody mention uh hypographs uh
earlier in the week and I can't remember
and this is sort of the driving this is
like the the donkey of the whole Theory
so there's actually a hyper graph hiding
behind each one of these models and what
I'm really doing is sampling hypergraphs
with a 50 degree sequence and lots of
constraints which we know is a difficult
problem but I do it per model and then I
can solve it very fast okay so this is
the Workhorse and so I end here with two
advertisements that I cannot skip
um I am one of the two editors of the
Journal called algebraic statistics so
if you're curious what are the algebraic
statistic there's a good journal to go
through because it has sort of the
latest developments all of the
leaders of the field have published at
least one paper and many more in this
journal uh it existed since 2010. and
now it's published by MSP
from here actually and also we have
there's a new NSF Institute relatively
in Chicago called MC Institute for
mathematics Co or mathematics and
statistics Innovations
is that the name
um so they have a special semester
actually quarter from September to
December
next year okay and it's about algebraic
statistics and our changing world
because they want to be really applied
and there are four workshops uh one of
the workshops that I think is relevant
to or relevant could be interesting to
many of you is the algebraic economics
Workshop if you get an invite from me uh
for this don't delete it right away
sounds it has to the name has to fit
within the the um
vision of The Institute but uh networks
play an important role here so do games
so we have you know combinatorial
auctions kind of like we have a lot of
stuff here so this will be a workshop
where networks are one of the main
themes and uh we'll be bringing people
who do applications
in the city of Chicago and more broadly
in social sciences uh and people who do
math and people who do stats and people
kind of stuff trying to like sort of
find a language to model the data around
us in Netflix so I invite you to sort of
check those out and with that I stop
foreign
I was wondering about the example that
you showed in Yen um what is a good
summary for the for the second picture
is there do we have any ideas uh sorry
that's my first question and my second
question is what do we mean by a good
summary uh like I mean here in this yeah
so it's a it's a
depends on when you ask me so by good
summary I mean uh
somebody claims that this is sufficient
to describe this data and to me that
means there's some model that generated
this data and that's a sufficient
statistic so that's what I mean but I
don't really spell it out uh each time
and uh I don't I did not actually
um
this no prompted us to think well what
other models do we know for directed
graphs that fit in this framework and uh
the models that fit in are basically
directed versions of the stochastic
block models
and so we have done this was in 20
16 and just last year we developed the
sampler for that model so I've not
tested it yet so I don't know the answer
of what fits this data but I mean yeah
okay more of a comment may I suggest to
use instead of using triangle counts to
test whether there's any more structure
in the network left that you're not
explained you centered triangle counts
or Center topic of counts because those
we on this under these kind of models in
some sense we understand
what they're doing they're I mean old
subgraph cam Center they are like
Independents you can normalize them
easily even in these cases doesn't have
to be Bernoulli it could be binomial in
your case it's probably binomial uh the
number of edges that you see or
something of that sort as long as you
can estimate those we can estimate the
variance we can normalize and then you
have a you can actually construct a
chi-square test from that yeah to see
whether there's any higher order
dependence left in the data so that that
would I mean I can do that in here
I have a straightforward statistic to
use when I'm doing a test and instead I
can just plug in these other things
instead
I mean that's a good point yeah you
started with a question where you
started with binary networks and then uh
combined them by basically taking the
union getting a multi-graph and then
asking the question how well that
represents uh your initial temporal data
there's one case where it's just
identical
in case of growing Networks
right an edge that is there will always
remain and that actually the final
Network can just be retraced back to
also temporal networks in fact this is
an important class preferential
attachment models and so on can you
comment on that I did not look at that
setting so I'm fixing n
so I'm fixing the size of the network
but in a circle sense your last example
of citations and authorships and so on
are exactly of that nature right yes I
know but this this was a yeah yes I yeah
so I cannot comment because these were
uh so only in the recent year that I
realized how how these stories fit
together and how this needs to be
continued
so I did not uh yeah yeah I didn't do
that
other questions
right let's thank Sonia and all our
speakers today
and we end here today and see you
tomorrow